والان الى السودان حيث دخلت المواجهات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم الساريه اسبوعها الرابع
بالفعل سهام الساعات
الساعات
الاولى الثاني والعشرين للمواجهات حملت
انباء عن سماع يدوي انفجارات وقصف في محيط
القصر الرئاسيه وسط الخرطوم وفي حي
الوبورات في الخرطوم بحري المواجهه للقصر
الجمهوري هذه المواجهات التي لم تنقطع من
بداء من بداء من بدايتها رغم اي اعلان عن
تهدئه او ما شابه ولكنها استمرت خاصه في
محيط القصر الجمهوري
والقياده العامه بينما تتجدد بين حين واخر
في اماكن مختلفه من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وقد دارت امس معارك ضاريه حول
المواقع الاستراتيجيه والمقر العسكريه
خصوصا في منطقه الخرطوم بحري
والانضم الينا من ام درمان مراسل الجزيره
ايضا المزيد من التفاصيل
هيثم كيف يبدو الوضع لديك حاليا
ما تزال من وقت الى اخر تسمع اصوات هذه
الانفجارات القويه من اتجاه الخرطوم
ومنطقه وسط الخرطوم تحديدا وايضا منطقه
الخرطوم بحري هذه المواجهات التي بدات
صباح اليوم بشكل مكثف في محيط القصر وكانت
هناك اصوات اسلحه ثقيله تسمع باستمرار
لفتره تجاوزت الساعه عقب ذلك كان هناك
ايضا تحليق لطيران الجيش التابع لسلاح
الجو الذي كان يحلق في سماء مدينه الخرطوم
وفيما يبدو كان يستهدف بعض المواقع
التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع هذه المواجهات
تستمر وان كانت بشكل متقطع احيانا في
ساعات النهار في تلك المناطق ولكنها ما
تزال موجوده على الارض ما يشير الى ان هذه
المواجهات ما تزال هي السيده الموقف رغم
الحديث الان عن الهدنه الجاريه ورغم ان
الاطراف قد وصلت الى جده في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه للبحث المفاوضات بشان
وقف اطلاق النار ولكن حتى الان يبدو ان
الامور ما تزال على الارض على ما هي عليه
طيله اسابيع الماضيه ونحن الان دخلنا
الاسبوع الرابع من عمر هذه المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ما
تزال النداءات الدوليه والمحليه تتواصل في
ظل هذا التصاعد والذي يعني يتسع ركعات
احيانا من مكان الى اخر ما بين
الخرطوم والخرطوم مناطق شرق النيل هي
المناطق الاكثر تضررا بهذه المواجهات هناك
طبعا ترحيب الان كبير من قبل القوى
السياسيه التي بدات تصدر العديد من
البيانات بشان هذه المباحثات التي يفترض
ان تبدا في جده بشان هذه
الاحداث ووقف التصعيد اطلاق النار وتامل
فيها ان تقود هذه المباحثات الى حث
الطرفين الى الوقف التصعيد والى ايجاد
هدنه طويله الامد على الاقل لبحث تفاصيل
الاوضاع الانسانيه وفتح الممرات الامنه
وتمكين المواطنين من قضاء حاجياتهم واع
فتح المؤسسات ربما الخدميه التي اتضررت هي
بجراء هذه المواجهات بشكل مباشر مع ادى
الى تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه كانيتيه
لانعكاسات هذه هي المواجهات المباشره في
كثير من النواحي سواء كانت معيشيه او
خدميه نعم في كل الاحوال
الحديث عن المفاوضات هو للتهدئه لمخفض
اطلاق النار ولكن ليس للوصول الى اي تسويه
سياسيه وهذا ما يعني يتم التاكيد عليه
خاصه من الجيش من القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
نعم الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه هي طبعا
لديها ثلاثه نقاط تقوم بالتدرج في المحور
الاول تهدف الى وقف اطلاق النار او وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار وفي المحور الثاني هو
مساله البحث الاوضاع الانسانيه وفتح
الممرات الامنه وتهدو في محورها الاخير
الى ايجاد تسويات حل هذه القضيه ولكن
التفاصيل هذه التسويه لم يتم الحديث عنها
الجيش كان واضحا في يبدو في موقفه وخاصه
من خلال
افاده البرهاني مبعوثه الخاص الذي الان
يزور العديد من العواصم الافريقيه يحمي
الرساله مفاده ان الجيش لن يفاوض الدعم
السريع باي موضوع سياسي او اي شان فيما
يخص البقاء القوات هذه من ناحيه سياسيه في
المستقبل ولكن التفاوض هو فقط حول الوقف
اطلاق النار والجوانب الانسانيه وهو حتى
الان ما دعموا الاطراف اخرى ان تكون هناك
يعني فرصه لايجاد حل سياسي ولكن حتى الان
يبدو ان المواقف فيما يبدو لديها بعض
الخطوط العريضه التي يرتكز عليها كل طرف
شكرا جزيلا هيثم اويت